[Applauso]
[Musica]
Come si chiamano i sette nani Vai Pronto
Lo vuoi Eolo cucciolo Mammolo pisolo
dotto Giusto giusto e Gongolo Gongolo
Bravi bravi
Gongolo Ogni volta che faccio questa
domanda la risposta è sempre la stessa
Gongolo o si dimentica o viene nominato
per ultimo
tra tutti i nani Gongolo e quello sempre
di buon umore Sempre allegro sorridente
bonario pensate che nella traduzione
inglese della favola non esiste la
traduzione di Gongolo ma il nano si
chiama
Happy tutto ciò che ci rende felici
tutto ciò che ci mette tipo un umore noi
o lo dimentichiamo o lo mettiamo per
ultimo
sin dall'infanzia siamo abituati a
guardare prima il difetto quello che non
va quello che c'è da migliorare torniamo
un attimo ai Sette Nani con un enorme
grazie ai magnifici fratelli Grimm e al
grande Walt Disney Perché
Allora
6 nani su 7 rappresentano dei difetti
delle anomalie qualcosa che non va per
esempio Qual è il difetto di Dotto
No non è il difetto di dotto essere
saccente madotto farfuglia mixa le
parole perde il filo del discorso si
confonde Mammolo e ipertipido si fa
rosso per qualsiasi cosa Brontolo
brontola Eolo allergico stanno disse in
continuazione cammina con
l'antistaminico dentro alla tasca e
pisolo si addormenta su tutto e tutti e
cucciolo non parla per tutta la durata
della favola e Gongolo che sempre
allegro di buon umore sorridente bonario
noi che facciamo lo dimentichiamo o lo
mettiamo per ultimo vero è che il nostro
cervello è programmato per intercettare
più velocemente pericoli e minacce ci
custodisce ci protegge da quello che
potrebbe danneggiare la nostra
sopravvivenza La nostra esistenza ma è
qui c'è il grande ma
funziona meglio in un clima di benessere
e buon umore quando siamo di cattivo
umore secondo voi è più facile o
difficile concentrarci creare
relazionarci a noi stessi e al vicino
diffice mentre quando siamo di buon
umore è più facile che tutto ciò avvenga
tutto ciò accada bisogna avere il
coraggio di riportare Gongolo nella
nostra vita nel nostro quotidiano In che
modo Praticando
decerismo in
invecerismo è una crasi tra due parole
leggerezza ed umorismo due concetti
strettamente connessi che camminano a
braccetto lungo la strada
straordinariamente complessa e
complicata mentre straordinaria della
nostra vita e leggerissimo è il modo di
guardare alla vita con uno sguardo
benevolo includendo tutti i nostri tutte
le nostre emozioni sia quelle spiacevoli
che quelle piacevoli e cogliendone gli
aspetti divertenti
il leggerissimo è
l'attivatore del buonumore
ed essere di buon umore non significa
avere dei livelli di umore nel nostro
corpo utili e funzionali alla nostra
esistenza e tutto ciò non è solo amara
sorrisi
Ciaia
vorremmo sebbene
No no
tutto ciò
è scienza e chimica esistono nel nostro
corpo dei meravigliosi
neurotrasmettitori e neuroni che si
attivi nella giusta dose ci donano
benessere uno di questi è il
potentissimo ed efficacissimo neuro
modulatore dell'umore la serotonina zia
serotonina e alla base
[Applauso]
sia serotonina e alla base di
innumerevoli funzioni vitali del nostro
corpo regola il ciclo sonno veglia ci
aiuta a dormire meglio favorisce la
digestione il senso di sazietà influisce
positivamente sul nostro sistema
cardiovascolare ed immunitario ed è
l'antidepressivo per eccellenza
adesso io faccio una domanda noi per
vivere abbiamo bisogno di bere di
mangiare giusto o e abbiamo bisogno di
dormire di andare in bagno giusto bene
in tutti i bisogni primari fisiologici
della nostra vita interviene zia
serotonina e quindi abbiamo bisogno di
stimolarla continuamente abbiamo bisogno
del buon umore dell'umore buono per
vivere così come il bere il mangiare il
dormire l'andare in bagno sono bisogni
primari della specie umana anche il buon
umore va promosso a bisogno
imprescindibile ineccepibile
incontrovertibile dell'umanità
io io io io io io io io
prego signore mi dica E come facciamo a
stimolare la produzione di serotonina e
quindi di buon umore
domanda interessante non me l'aspettavo
proprio
Complimenti si riflette un attimo
bisogna mettere a sistema il buon umore
nelle nostre giornate
calendarizzare quotidianamente momenti
divertenti spazi di piacere tempi
sorridenti che favoriscono la produzione
di serotonina ore 16 collo con il capo
ore 17 accompagnare i bambini in piscina
ore 18 guardare un video divertente che
mi faccia ridere
Due relazionarsi tutti i giorni a
persone che praticano leggerissimo
persone che ci fanno ridere persone che
ci Rilassano persone che ci fanno
sentire liberi
alimentazione consapevole conoscere
quello che mangiamo e l'impatto che ogni
cibo ha sul nostro corpo il 90 per cento
della serotonina è prodotta
dall'intestino Quindi fate i bravi meno
picchi di zucchero bianco più Spicchi di
frutta colorata meno chip industriali
che chiudono
più cibi naturali che aprono
meno cibi
meno cibi che appesantiscono più cibi
che alleggeriscono e questo prezioso
suggerimento è già presente nella lingua
napoletana Voi sapete come si dice
digerire in napoletano
Alì a alleggerire
quattro fare sport qualsiasi tipo di
sport importante che ci diverta ci
piaccia ci faccia ridere ci faccia
giocare ci riporti a giocare come
facevamo da bambini e questo prezioso
suggerimento è già presente nella lingua
inglese sia fare sport che giocare si
traducono con un solo verbo tu Play
quindi preghiamo di più
riposo
e come il numero dei nani arriviamo a 6
e 7 insieme quindi 6 e 7 saper cogliere
la dibuffi della vita avere la capacità
di ridere di sé degli imprevisti e delle
difficoltà delle nostre giornate in
maniera inclusiva e costruttiva c'è un
passaggio bellissimo di Alice nel paese
delle meraviglie quando verso la fine il
Bianconiglio fa Alice andiamocene via
che Qui sono tutti normali
E facciamolo ogni tanto qualcosa di
folle
facciamolo ogni tanto qualcosa di folle
pratichiamo lo sto leggerissimo Signore
signori noi non Salviamo vite possiamo
stare più leggeri possiamo sorridere di
più E se anche qui in mezzo ci fosse
qualcuno che salva vite stare più
leggero gliene farebbe salvare di più
esiste una differenza enorme tra essere
seri ed essere seriosi essere seriosi
significa essere rigidi passant
essere seri significa essere
centrati responsabili affidabili adesso
seriamente faccio una domanda Vi chiedo
Secondo voi quanto tempo sorride un
adulto medio al giorno forza
date un tempo un giorno
5 minuti 3 minuti
un'ora la risposta è 40 secondi
e adesso Facciamo un esperimento per un
minuto vi chiedo di restare tutti quanti
così vai un minuto vai verde Avverti
così bravi Vai Benny Guardate quanto
diventiamo più affascinanti vai adesso
per favorirvi guardatevi anche un po'
tra di voi perché ci sono delle facce
che meritano Secondo me Vai vai tieni
tieni tieni tieni anche su Eh forza
forza vai vai vai guarda poi non mollare
Tieni tieni che un esperimento Vai voi
pensate che io questo esperimento lo
metto sempre in questo punto perché così
chi non è venuto a vedere o chi guarda
il video Adesso pensa che ci stiamo
divertendo tantissimo Vai vai tieni
tieni tieni tieni tieni tieni tieni
tieni ferma non riesco aspetta
[Applauso]
continua
No no l'applauso il sorriso Guarda io
non voglio sapere il video Dopo l'uomo
daglielo
ok 10 9 8 di risoluzione 7 6 5 non
dovete contare io quattro Tre due uno
uno uno
come
Allora vedo vedo qualcuno che si sta
toccando massaggiando questi Che cosa
sono muscoli e se dopo un minuto di
trazione e sentiamo un po' indolenziti
ci danno un po' fastidio vuol dire che
questo gesto lo facciamo poco se fate
questo gioco con i bambini loro dopo 4
minuti e mezzo di orologio vi
guarderanno e vi diranno ma perché non
ce la fai più
il leggerissimo il leggerissimo innato
nei bambini ci viene dato in dotazione
sin dalla nascita
Ecco proprio loro proprio i bambini Io
da anni sono un formatore un docente
universitario un clan dottore nelle
parti pediatrici e proprio lì io ho
imparato e sperimentato sulla mia pelle
che il buon umore è cura di sé e cura
degli altri spesso le aziende le persone
i gruppi mi chiamano e mi chiedono Ma
come facciamo a migliorare la
comunicazione la relazione a crescere a
diventare grandi io nonostante lo studio
la ricerca L'esperienza è una risposta
non l'ho mai trovata fino a quando non
ho incontrato Caterina
in questa foto Caterina aveva quattro
anni adesso ne ha 12 è bellissima e sta
bene e quindi
io vado in ospedale a fare dei giochi di
magia anche con loro Un giorno vado in
ospedale e questo gioco È prende una
pallina rossa la metto nella loro mano
loro Soffiano e ne diventano due vado
con questa pallina da Caterina e le dico
Caterina facciamo questo gioco Lei mi
guarda e mi fa No non lo voglio fare
sono grande 4 anni sono grandi
Caterina è come si fa a diventare grandi
Lei mi guarda e mi fa così
alzandosi sulle punte e li io la
risposta li capisco che per diventare
grandi bisogna stare leggeri bisogna
lasciare andare i propri pesi e quelli
degli altri a terra restare semplici e
sollevarsi sulle punte come fanno i
bambini e per questo vi chiedo per
favore di mettervi tutti in piedi
e al mio 3 come Caterina con
leggerissimo alzarci tutti sulle punte 1
2 3
[Applauso]